little hadley angel lies motionless
sick with malaria
she was admitted here to kasumu county
hospital a few days ago with a very high
fever and convulsions
she's only a year old and her mother
masu velma is beside herself with worry
i was a little a little bit of a fever
and the baby was not feeling the baby
was not playing as usual
i'm very much worried about the
the child
because she's my first one
i didn't love her
malaria is one of the biggest killers
known to man but
angel will survive
she's been vaccinated with three doses
of a groundbreaking malaria vaccine it's
probably saved her life
sister suleiman has been a pediatric
nurse for 10 years
she's lost count of the number of
children who have died of malaria
but the vaccine she tells me is saving
lives
i can say that there has been a very
high reduction in the level of admission
like what we used to see before like you
see most of
our
our pets are now not occupied so the
vaccine is having a real impact yes the
vaccine has really made a very
big impact
because long before you could get the
entire pet occupancy at least more than
70 percent with malaria
but as opposed to now you are getting
like 3 out of 16 that is a very minimal
percentage
the world health organization has been
trialling gsk's rts s vaccine in
sub-saharan africa countries like kenya
ghana and malawi it's been so effective
that it's hoped it can save the lives of
millions of african children they're
vaccinated you have to totally according
to the number of doses it's their first
dose the second dose this is the first
ever vaccine against a human parasite
and that's why it was so difficult to
engineer it's taken a hundred years of
failed attempts to get here
this is africa's great hope finally a
malaria vaccine that could break this
vicious cycle of death disease
and poverty
and this is ideal breeding place for all
yeah i think that and that's why they're
trying to uh evacuate it that was a
pipeline
yeah so that pipeline is a it's also one
of the breeding areas from malaria
to me
malaria hits the poorest the most and
especially the children from those
communities
home visits like this one track the
spread and identify babies who might be
infected
but african children can now look
forward to a future free from the
scourge of malaria
george is ready to go home after his
battle with the disease
this vaccine means he might never have
to come back with malaria
again
ashish joshi sky news in kisumu in kenya